The Language Made Up Entirely of Whistles
In Spanish, “Silbo Gomero” means “Gomeran
whistling,” which is an apt name for the
language “spoken” on La Gomera in the
Canary Islands.
You see, this language is made up entirely
of whistling sounds.
The language was used by the Guanches—the
aboriginal people of the Canary Islands—long
before Spanish settlement.
It is a whistled form of the original Guanche
language, which died out around the 17th century.
Not much is known about that spoken language
of those people save for a few words recorded
in the journals of travellers and a few others
that were integrated into the Spanish spoken
on the Canary Islands.
It is believed that spoken Guanche had a simple
phonetic pattern that made it easily adaptable
to whistling.
The language was whistled across the Canary
Islands, popular on Gran Canaria, Tenerife,
and El Hiero as well as La Gomera.
It’s likely that the first Guanches were
from North Africa and brought the idea of
a whistled language with them, as there are
several different whistling languages that
have been recorded there.
From the time of Guanche settlement, the language
evolved into Guanche whistling, and then to
silbo.
Today, silbo is a whistled form of Spanish.
It was adopted in the 16th century after the
last of the Guanches adapted their whistled
language to Spanish.
The language works by replicating timbre variations
in speech.
One study showed that silbo is recognized
in the “language center” of the brain
by silbo whistlers, though regular Spanish
speakers who were not silbo whistlers simply
recognized it as whistling.
As to why such a version of a language would
originally be developed at all, it’s thought
that silbo was developed as a form of long
distance communication.
The island of La Gomera is awash with hills,
valleys, and ravines.
A whistle can travel up to two miles across
such a landscape, and the whistler doesn’t
have to expend as much energy as he would
by hiking or shouting and, in the latter case,
the whistled message is heard farther away
besides.
When La Gomera was largely an agricultural
island, crops and herds of animals like sheep
would be spread out across the hills, and
herders would use the language to communicate
with one another across these large distances.
Speaking via whistling still saw widespread
use as late as the 1940s and 50s, when another
purpose was discovered.
If a fire started, the Guardia Civil would
make civilians drop what they were doing to
help, but the locals wouldn’t get paid for
their work, despite the Guardia receiving
a payment.
So, locals passed a message along by whistling,
telling others to hide when the Guardia Civil
approached.
Because the Guardia Civil didn’t understand
silbo, it was a sort of “secret” language
among the locals.
Unfortunately, economic hardship around the
1950s put silbo-speaking in the decline, as
most of the whistlers were forced to move
to find better opportunities.
The introduction of roads and the invention
of the mobile phone also contributed to the
decline, as they made silbo largely unnecessary.
By the end of the twentieth century, the whistled
language was dying out.
However, as it is an integral part of the
island’s history, there was interest in
reviving the language to preserve the culture.
The call for revival was met with mixed emotions,
because many people thought of it as a “peasant”
language of little use to them.
Despite the protests, every primary school
child on La Gomera today is required to learn
the whistling language, with it being taught
in the island’s schools.
The revival of silbo has other benefits, too.
Silbo is one of the few whistling languages
that has been studied in-depth, and researchers
believe that its simplicity (with only 2-4
vowels and 4 consonants) holds the key to
discovering how other languages developed,
despite not knowing the exact origin of silbo
itself.